[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi à 17
mai fabienne thibeault est l'une des
toutes premières chanteuses de starmania
la comédie musicale de luc plamondon et
michel berger le 7 juin elle sera sur la
scène à rambouillet pour un concert au
profit de l'habituel de la commune est
réalisable selanne c'est le nom de la
nouvelle création du pavé volubile en
résidence à la ferme de bel ébat de
juillan pro un spectacle pour tous ces
deux élections sur le racisme et
esclavage
le 20 mai c'est aussi la 13e édition de
la nuit des musées que vous et de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines
participent
une soirée placée sous le signe du
vintage quarante ans plus tard le nom de
fabienne thibeault est toujours aussi un
des social de celui de starmania la
chanteuse franco québécoise y
interpréter marie jeanne à la serveuse
automate et c'était de la comédie
musicale de luc plamondon et michel
berger le 7 juin elle sera un
rambouillet pour un concert caritatif
elle chantera les plus grands titres
écoutés
[Musique]
je change
1978 la france découvre la voix de
fabienne thibeault à 26 ans elle et
marie jeanne dans starmania
près de quarante ans plus tard l'opéra
rock ne l'a pas quitté star manière
complètement fondatrice de même c'est à
partir de starmania que le public m'a
freiné la rencontre ma cheville
starmania et est un vraiment un
patrimoine de notre culture populaire
musicale
c'est beaucoup tube beaucoup de paiement
cip centre est extrêmement et fondateur
de ce qu'on vit
[Musique]
webo le 7 juin elle sera accompagnée de
cinq chanteurs ils mêleront titres
incontournables de la comédie musicale
et morceaux québécois une soirée
organisée avec le lion's club de
rambouillet la vie de la cité a montré
qu'il y avait ce problème de pour les
personnes isolées pour les personnes
dépendantes de trouver un délit q la
disposition pour pouvoir circuler pour
aller faire ses courses pour aller chez
le médecin il fallait demander à la
voisine et quand on a un problème de
personnes isolées
c'est difficile le club espère récolter
8500 euros lors de cette soirée pour que
ce titre de luc plamondon et michel
berger ne soit plus d'actualité
tout ça
[Musique]
à la verrière ce sont les rockeurs
locaux qui seront à l'honneur samedi
cinq groupes de la maison de la musique
et de la danse proposeront des reprises
et des compositions personnelles et ça
se passera sur la scène de la merise de
la musique encore mais de la musique
compte et c'est avec rise up la nouvelle
création de la compagnie pavé volubile
c'est à découvrir à la ferme de bel ébat
de guyancourt le 20 mai prochain
55 minutes pour voyager à travers des
contes et des récits afro américains
mais c'est aussi une réflexion sur
l'esclavagé le racisme reportages
réalisés avec patrick jacques de dixmude
et mélinda corrézien chocolat les juges
à un ton joyeux des visages souriant une
contrebasse entraînante avec rise up
praliné gay-para hélène labarrière parle
de manière facétieuse du racisme de l'
esclavage l'aise en psy en veut le
traduire c'est soulevez vous et c'est
aussi
et un mot clé de plein de mouvements de
protestation aux états unis sur plein de
pages qui sont les blacks là ce matin
les ferguson le théâtre comme tout le
spectacle vivant comme toute création
comme but ultime que les gens se posent
des questions c'est pas à nous de donner
les réponses des récits de tradition
orale des comptes afro américains et
caribéens rise up est un aboutissement
de 30 ans de travail le jazz musiques
emblématiques de la traite négrière a
aussi toute sa place donner à entendre
les mots qui sont pas dit et puis de
donner aussi une dimension poétique qui
ailleurs une autre que la musique
raconte aussi une histoire qui est
peut-être pas la même que va faire
entendre l'histoire ce principal déjà
c'est transmettre les cris puisque c'est
quand même ça aurait pas ces courtes
donc habillé et tourne ajoute dessus des
mentions peu théâtral mais
l'exigence et le contre la restitution
de co2 soit pas que la mise en scène
mange d'histoire adultes ou enfants les
lectures sont multiples rise up ou la
démonstration que l' esclavage
appartient à notre histoire commune la
nuit des musées revient pour sa 13e
édition et cette année encore le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
ouvrira ses portes
l'occasion de découvrir deux nuits les
nouveaux locaux et surtout l'exposition
en cours
le point avec julie sauvageau du musée
lucie sauvageau bonjour vous êtes la
responsable action culturelle du musée
de la vie et 50 ans participent
cette fois encore à la nuit des musées
c'est la 13ème édition senio ça c'est ça
alors que va-t-il se passer ce week-end
alors cette année la nuit des musées ce
sera au tour de l'exposition au vintage
regarde dans le rétro en lien avec cette
exposition on a souhaité faire un
événement autour du rétro gaming puisque
c'est un phénomène très tendance qui
permet de jouer à des jeux vidéo
d'époque c'est à dire du début du début
pendant des années 1970 au milieu des
années 1990 donc c'est au ça permet de
jouer sur des consoles d'époque à des
jeux d'époque
ça c'est la première partie de cette
nuit des musées la deuxième partie sera
autour des 40 ans du musée puisque c'est
cette année l'année anniversaire de la
création de l'écomusée de saint quentin
en yvelines en 1977
l'une des muses et une nuits l'idée
c'est de découvrir aussi peut-être le
musée d'une autre manière
oui l'idée c'est d'avoir un moment
convivial sur un temps où d'habitude le
musée fermé donc la nuit en soirée c'est
vraiment un événement qui est fait pour
appréhender le musée différemment et
puis pour venir en famille ou entre amis
c'est des propositions qui souvent sont
s'adresse à un public assez jeune etc
voilà une autre occasion de
miro musée de manière peut-être plus
décontractée que d'habitude vous parliez
de retrogaming quelques monde jeu
peut-être ou de console je ne sais pas
qui se représentent
alors oui des noms de consoles alors bon
les traditionnels sega amstrad pas
toutes ces consoles là qui ont marqué
bien des générations d jeu pacman super
mario bros des jeux bien sûr qu'ils sont
identiques
il est que tout le monde connaît même
s'il n'ya pas jouer forcément notamment
les plus jeunes générations sous leurs
formes anciennes
cette semaine c'est siri la date de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois qui nous donne son coup
de coeur écouter cette semaine notre
coup de coeur et le film le procès du
siècle
réalisé par michael jackson avec rachel
weisz et tom wilkinson
je voulais toutefois son théâtre il est
plus vrai avec une femme est morte dans
la voiture du sénateur ted kennedy
atchapa quick peut danser du soi-disant
chambres à gaz ou fixe le gora digital
historienne et auteure reconnue défend
farouchement la mémoire de nos locaux
elle se voit confronté à un
universitaire extrémistes avocats de
thèse controversée sur le régime nazi
david irving condamné au défi de prouver
l'existence de la shoah dollars à
quiconque montre un document prouvant un
sujet sensible du film est traité sous
forme de thriller juridique et
historique
n'est ce pas met en lumière la tentative
de manipulation et de révisionnisme de
différence de l'holocauste à auschwitz
est aussi au coeur de la négation de
l'holocauste
au delà du scénario précis le film de
mike jackson revient sur un sujet
d'actualité désaltérer speed up actifs
et news le mensonge historique un trou
ce toit par conséquent il n'y a jamais
eu de chambres à gaz bakouba de leur
poste ils voulaient à sedan il a je ne
suis pas servi par d'excellents acteurs
ce film efficace bien écrit et
interprété se révèle essentielle et
passionné n'a jamais conduit le procès
du siècle est à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe n'aurait le cinéma
des yeux d'elsa de saint cyr l'école
organise un ciné rencontres le vendredi
19 mai vous pourrez découvrir le film
les dernières nouvelles du cosmos c'est
l'histoire d'hélène trentenaire et
auteur de livres aux questions
existentielles et pourtant elle ne peut
ni écrire ni parler et d échange avec
l'association addes autistes se feront à
l'issue de la projection le théâtre
espace collège de plaisir va vibrer au
rythme tzigane et yiddish les yeux noirs
vous entraîne dans un monde sans
frontières au pays des roms et des
poètes
regardez
[Musique]
un voyage à vivre aussi aux
clayes-sous-bois avec la musique
d'angelo de bar le musicien manouche est
reconnu comme un gars un guitariste pas
donc du jazz manouche au talentueux il
sera sur la scène de l'espace philippe
noiret avec son quartet
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nathalie dossier continue son
exploration d'autres domaines
artistiques après ses adieux à l'opéra
en 2013 la soprano française est devenue
comédienne et elle sera seule sur la
scène du théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines dans round un
monologue d'une femme d'une femme
ravagée par les fantômes de la shoah
[Musique]
qu'ils attendent là si c'est bien lui
qui patientent
[Musique]
m
pour et anéantir mais défense
clash encore ne l'est pas
[Musique]
de la colère présents
un dernier rendez vous à noter à
vélizy-villacoublay cette fois c'est la
neuvième édition du battle duo mythique
une centaine de danseurs hip hop venus
de toute l'île de france qui va
s'affronter les sélections commence à
14h à la battle elle c'est à 17h le
cette culture est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis et je
vous dis à mercredi prochain
non